describe your approach like okay you're
starting a company from scratch
i would say like it's just a question of
priorities and i would say this versus
priorities is building an awesome team
they're recruiting like high-level
people and then like
really setting a cultural foundation
around that so that's like the that's
the non like non-poking fun way of
looking at it is like that's that's
their priority so what's your priority
when you like start an endeavor
[Music]
did you see this email i sent you so i
forwarded you uh and then like an
investor update i got
uh did you did you see that email i know
from who
uh well i can't say but because i was
sort of like you know this person's
smart they actually sold the company
before which address did you send it to
uh
i don't know maybe you're like hustle
one i don't know but just see if you see
an email from me anyways i'll just
explain to you you don't even need to
read the email
basically this is like i was like this
is so different
than anything i would do and i was like
if if this person wasn't already
successful
like they did they built a cool company
before this they
are a smart person i've met them before
but they um
you know their their company updates or
their investor updates are highly like
um
aspirational like so they haven't
launched yet the team is like it's like
oh the team is growing we have like i
don't know i don't know how many people
they have like 30 40 people now um
we did our you know a second off site
because remote work you know it's hard
to build our bonds and on our off site
we played these games and we did this
mission statement thing and here's our
values and then like on top of the
values we're thinking about like how to
build a culture that's really you know
transparent collaborative
and like again haven't launched yet no
revenue no nothing uh but like a
professional photographer
but yeah have a professional
photographer the update is like super
robust
and like again on one hand i'm like when
i read this i'm just like oh no like
this is this is like it's like watching
a car drive off a cliff it's like this
is like all the parts of a startup
except for the important parts um and
like i know they must be doing the
important they must be building the
product too it's not like they're not
uh but like i would never prioritize
these things in my own companies i know
you're the same way where we're both a
little bit like
you know brash and like you know you're
like no the office doesn't have cups
like we use these little kids yeah like
can you put your hand like this
[Music]
yeah like
they don't call me sam hose water park
or nothing like grab the hose and suck
them down like if you need some i'll
bring it to your desk so you don't have
to waste time he's convenient the hose
is 18 foot i sprung for the big one
and so i know you're like me where like
we do this like very bootleg company
building and like you know oh
like we look up and it's like oh [__] we
have 18 dudes okay diversity yeah okay
like we're you know we're gonna change
that or it's like
the company culture is like oh yeah um
come to my come to my house tonight i'm
gonna cook for you guys i don't know
what like so can you guys just stop at
safeway and just buy like a bunch of
chips
like everybody likes chips right it's
like yeah all right everyone like
subscribe
everybody go buy your favorite bag of
chips that's what we're doing tonight
like you know it's like these kind of
company building at the minimum and it's
like the as you go style
and then i see this and i'm like either
like either there's just like many play
styles that's how you you can win in
different ways
or their way wrong or i'm way wrong i
don't know what do you think about this
sort of thing
i think that for a very particular type
of person i wouldn't be concerned
about this type of email i think that
you should most likely assume you are
not that person
um
not even like you but like anyone anyone
they should all they should default
today or not like if you are uh you know
like uh
some like big swinging dick some big
deal
here's the analogy it's like steve jobs
didn't like you know he was like a
perfectionist he would like build it and
then release the perfect product he
wasn't trying to iterate he didn't ask
consumers for feedback you know like
early on early and often he was a
product visionary genius
okay but like to assume that you're
steve jobs-ish yeah that assume that
you're that is like
dangerous that's a dangerous path to go
down i think this is a horrible idea you
and i have a friend that started a
company and when they were only two
people him and the business partner
they hired a ceo coach so they could
help with culture building
and uh that's another sign but yeah i
think and they would go to like retreats
like for like right
this type of stuff so no i think that
uh
this is not a good sign
it's not very good at all
have you um
i guess like what's your describe your
approach like okay you're starting a
company from scratch
i would say like it's just a question of
priorities and i would say this person's
priorities is building an awesome team
they're recruiting like high-level
people and then like
really setting a cultural foundation
around that so that's like the that's
the non like non-poking fun way of
looking at it is like that's that's
their priority so what's your priority
when you like start an endeavor so yeah
i'm doing that now so like i'm gonna
start getting into it and we can talk
about it but i'm gonna start getting
into something and i'm thinking like all
right is this something that i want to
build to sell or is this something that
i want to run forever because that
actually kind of matters on how you set
up your entity um
so i think about like what do i want
personally what type of life do i want
and how long do i want to operate this
for so that's what would you do
differently let's say build for bill own
forever or build a sale what's the
what's the core difference well if you
want to pay yourself from the business
as you go an llc makes sense um if you
want to sell the company and you're
willing to not pay yourself a little bit
or you only want to pay yourself as a
w-2 then you want to be a
like a c corp and if you want to um
i guess you could be an escort but if
you want to sell your company in in five
plus years and take advantage of qsbs
which is ten million dollars of sac or
sorry three million dollars of tax
savings then you for sure want to be a c
corp because you can't get that on the
other two so i i would think about like
that like what type of structure do i
want this to be of course i have a
history of getting hits so like if you
don't have a history of like making
money then like i wouldn't even worry
about this [__] you know what i mean
like i've proven to myself that like if
i say i'm gonna do something i follow
through you know i'm not you don't want
to be the nerd that just buys business
cards before you even have anything done
great point okay so that's like
literally a company structure but um and
by the way i i think i told you this i
one of the kind of like tax slash
uh lawyer people that's like kind of
advising us they gave us a pretty great
structure that gives us best of both
they're like just have a c corp that
owns the business assets
and that's what will be eligible for
qsbs down the road
but then
uh the c corp will pay your llc's
uh you know your llc's for each you you
know the co-founders uh like as a
management thing and so you're gonna get
you're gonna get personally paid out
through your llc
um and then but you still retain the
long-term benefits of raising money or
selling a c-corp yeah that's but is the
is the stock owned by the c-corp
uh yeah so the company well c-corp is
the one issuing the stock it has the
stock that's the stock that we want to
so if you do a stock purchase and we can
either we and then the llc doesn't need
to own that stock yeah that's the right
management company that's like savvy
[__] that i would have to like look into
make sure i'm doing it right because
there's a there's a clock you need to
own it for five years additionally what
you could do is you can issue
shares to family members in different
trusts so many many people could take
advantage of the qsbs and other uh
long-term capital gains things like that
so i think a little bit about that stuff
um and i i think like what right now i'm
every business that i'm thinking of i'm
think about how many employees do i need
to run this and what type of employee am
i going to have to hire because when you
go big with some ideas you're going to
hire these like smart ass ex harvard x
facebook type of folks um you don't have
to but you know like that like that type
of thing or
is this like no i could actually hire
this like 60 000 a year person but where
are they going to be coming from and do
i actually want or not want to work with
that type of person right so i think
about who am i going to have to empl
employ and what the business model is
going to be and so how stressful will
that be advertising was really stressful
because we had to go out and well you're
you're in it now you got to hunt every
single month and that could be a that
can be a bit stressful and so now i'm
looking at what it's a little bit more
recurring which is less stressful so i'm
thinking a lot about business model i'm
thinking about what type of lifestyle i
want and i'm thinking about who i'd have
to hire
and you're thinking about these things
but that's not your priority list right
so like i mean like in terms of action
right so that's thinking and planning
cool that'll take you a couple days to
be kind of noodling on that stuff
in terms of how do you like that's
actually the hardest action that's
actually the hardest part is figuring
out because that's what ben said that's
figuring out what figure out what you
want but in terms of the action i figure
out
i narrow it down to
what's the one thing that can make this
fail or work and so let's just say that
i'm creating um
uh let's say i'm creating uh hubspot
let's say i'm hubspot a few years ago
i'm creating hubspot so there's like a
few items that could that need to work
or at least i would think they need to
work in order to make happen so like can
i recruit engineers is probably one
um do people want this um and are my
engineers even capable enough to create
this and so if i'm hubspot well
salesforce exists so i actually think
that um people can build this like it's
i'm i'm able to build this product and
number two i know a bunch of engineers
and i'm pretty good at sales i think i
can um
i think i can recruit engineers so then
then it's like well but do people want
this so that's like the the like okay
boom that's it that's the thing where
it's like i have to figure that out
before i move on to the next steps and
so i go out and try to solve that for a
company like hubspot i would actually
just do tons of phone calls and i would
make a judgment call based on that for
this like little small copywriting thing
the try copy that dot com that thing
that yeah i i just no with that i just
put a pre-sale on there and i got five
thousand dollars of pre-sales and i've
with trends we had fifty thousand
dollars of pre-sales so depending on how
easy the transaction is if it's a
thousand dollars or less and
transactional value i can probably
create a landing page and pre-sell it we
pre-sold this uh thousand dollar thing
for trends and we're gonna charge 10
grand for it when it came out we
pre-sold i think we got a hundred
thousand dollars so we got a thousand
dollars from 100 different people
to launch it and so if it's under a
thousand dollars my first step is
uh
selling it and giving me giving me
myself one month to pull it off
right yeah that's exactly right i
to me i simplify it like
um
how do i make sure like how do i figure
out do people want it step one do people
want this
and that's either pre-selling talking to
people
just kind of my own gut do people want
this second thing is where will i get
customers
okay i think i could probably get the
first 10 customers from here first
hundred customers from there but like on
an ongoing basis do i have like a
repeatable way to get customers
and
if i know they answer those two
questions then i just go and i don't do
other things besides those two things i
build the thing that they want and i
give it to them and see if they want to
see if they actually love it or if they
just kind of like it and then i see if
the way to get customers actually works
and once i do those two things i don't
really want to do anything else besides
those two things for like a long period
of time and like
all the other stuff raising money
company culture hiring
um
you know corporate structure naming
branding uh packaging design
all comes after yeah and you have to
my opinion is not only do you have to
not
you have to
like say i'm not going to worry about
that at this point but you also have to
say i'm actively actually going to avoid
it so it's like i'm going to like
actively not care about it you know what
i mean like you have to like and you
kind of have to like take that stance um
and i think there's actually some
products where the question is not
do people want this so like there's some
stuff that i'll create that i'm like
well i already know people want this
like i know they're gonna buy it the
question is like can i even get
customers to this repeatedly
um and then that's actually gonna tell
you a couple tactics that helped me with
this yeah i wonder if you did something
like this so i have learned that it's
actually best to be a little bit what
i'll call brutal about this okay so what
do i mean by brutal about this it is
very easy like when somebody hears that
oh yeah you you first figure out do
people want this and you try to like you
know pre-sell it or offer it to them and
see if they sign up for the wait list or
they they pre-buy or whatever
and then you figure out where am i gonna
get customers repeatedly and like you
test that marketing channel and like
those only two things you do you say no
to everything else that sounds so simple
and then you like
tell someone go try to build a startup
and they'll do everything else besides
those two things that's because that's
like the embarrassing hard stuff yeah
because it's the hard stuff and if they
if it doesn't work the car doesn't move
anywhere whereas you can do a whole
bunch of other stuff and it feels like
you're moving
but the reality is you're not moving
forward you're moving sideways and so
but at least moving feels like you're
moving and so people will gravitate
towards those things so let me give you
some examples
um yesterday there was a tweet
about furkan who was my my old
co-founder my last startup and furcon is
like you know a man of action you know a
few words a lot of action and um you
know like if you ever asked him like
when do you think he could do this it is
rare for him to not be like i should be
able to ship it tonight now he only hits
the tonight thing like i would say
thirty percent of the time like thirty
percent of the time nothing happens
seventy percent of the time he gets like
a crappy version that's like not ready
but like he'll at 2am there will be a
message from him be like here's where i
left it
and
you know like 10 or 20 times he actually
finishes the thing but he almost never
says anything besides like yeah we
should do that tonight
um and so i learned that from him and
every engineer we hired learned that
from him we're like you can't give him a
timeline that's not tonight he's if you
say something besides tonight he's just
like what the [__] are you talking about
so
he now has this new like incubator thing
uh called f dot inc
what was that picture of that dude it
looked sexy as hell right like he bought
this ten thousand square foot or at
least ten thousand square foot space in
fort mason it was beautiful when
everybody was leaving san francisco and
uh and then remote work shut down all
the offices and schools and in-person
events he was like the only buyer he was
like yeah i want a big space
uh i'm in the middle of san francisco in
the best part of san francisco so he's
like you could see the water the bridge
he got ten thousand square feet he's
like i'm gonna put a robotics lab a
hardware lab desks i'm just gonna have a
bunch of engineers come make stuff here
you don't have to pay me rent like just
come back and it's like beautiful like
it looks like he's been renovating it so
it's like it started with an empty blank
shell and now it's like looks awesome
so does he make a story does he make
money from that or is he just spending
money hoping that one of the companies
he
he's like he's made a bunch of money and
he's also just like he invests in the
incubator company and the companies that
are there invested a bunch of them and
like those are already doing well so
somebody tweeted out somebody who's
working out of there they go
uh one thing that furcon does around the
office is if a developer spends like
more than a day i think it's like if you
spend more than a day on localhost which
is basically just means like you're
building your website project but you
didn't ship it to the world like nobody
else besides your laptop can access the
site
um
if you spend more than a day he'll just
start calling you localhost until you
ship it here stop using your name and
he'll just call you localhost because
you oh you're just local host now right
like you don't want people to use your
products so you just all right local
host you want to get lunch and like
i wanted to tweet this out i knew people
would take it the wrong way but like
that is a style we kind of incubated at
our last startup it's sort of like bully
management and it's not that you're
bullying people it's that you're
bullying your values it's like
how do i like live my values instead of
just say we care about you know like
building things fast it's like
no if you don't build things and get it
to customers you will get ridiculed here
because that is not cool in our books
you want cool you want respect then you
got to do the thing we respect and like
if you don't we're going to tease you
until you do it i was giving a guy a
hard time in the trends group because he
posted hey so i've got six podcast
episodes already recorded
can someone give me an answer on which
hosting platform is better and my i
reply to go
well that's not really the important
question the important question is why
did you record six with like just
release one
and and right and just post it it was
like well by the way so i started this
podcast when i started this podcast what
did i do i message you on facebook i go
hey i'm starting a podcast that i think
you know
is gonna be awesome uh you know here's
the concept
at that i was literally making it up as
i was i made up the name made up the
concept right there on the spot i knew i
wanted to do a podcast generally and i
go
i go um you know you have this awesome
audience but no audio content i'll make
great audio content if you'll put in
front of your audience and then i was
like i'm gonna send you the first i'll
send you the first episode later today
there was no first episode i then go
book a studio record the episode and
send it to you within 24 hours
in order for you to like see that i'm
like being legitimate it was live like
uh two weeks later right yeah i was like
okay this is ready to go like here it's
nobody's listening to it but it's in the
store you can go listen to the podcast
if you want to the guy was like we got
we got six done and i'm like but that's
not the question that you d like the
question is why do you have six done and
done none live like that's just crazy
right because people default to they
it's embarrassing and it's
to post that [__] so let me give you
some other examples of this of being
brutal about it uh at monkey inferno
when when we were working there we would
sometimes let like kind of interesting
engineering guys like just hang out in
our office
and they would we'd just like just work
from here no you don't need to pay us
it's not a wework it's like the sick
office we got extra space just come here
and work just bring some good energy and
so these guys came and they uh they were
working there
they had this idea that was really cool
and then they were like
they would always ask us questions that
were like that like
uh this investor is interested well you
know we're thinking about raising money
you know how should we think about this
can you look at our debt can you do this
and that i'm like
and it's like hey is your guys you guys
product do you have your product built
like do you have users it's like it's
just like those are more important than
this fundraising stuff but like i get it
it's flattering when an investor wants
to give you money but like now that
investor just took over your day like
and now your day is all about that
instead of like the main thing right
like hey guys and whatever happens
so then no so then they get they get
into y combinator they're like oh we got
into y combinator and we're like awesome
those guys will keep you on track
and then over the next six weeks it was
like
yo um
you're nyc like what's going on what's
it like to be an aussie i've never done
it like heard it's awesome and they're
like oh yeah the office hours are great
they're bringing up this and that and
we're like hey so how many users you
guys got and they'd be like um and they
would like they didn't know the number
oh my god and me and fer khan just
looked at each other like
all right new rule
if we ask you how many users you have
how many daily active users you have you
don't know the number
like 10 push-ups and they're like haha
we're like no we're serious about that
and then they they still didn't know for
two more days and they had to look up
the dashboard and we're like all right
bishop's not working so we took a marker
and we started writing a giant zero
on the like the wall behind them
and we're like this is the number of
users you have according to us because
you don't know so we're just gonna keep
putting zero here
and like it's your job to like change
this to be like the number of users you
have every day when you come to the
office you're gonna see this giant zero
above your head until you change that
and like again this worked and like all
of a sudden they started thinking about
how many users they had they wanted they
didn't want that giant zero hanging over
their head
and i've just seen many versions of this
i've heard a story about peter thiel
doing this too
peter thiel's values were all about like
focus and so his thing was
everybody at paypal when he was the ceo
of paypal would have one thing that they
were responsible for and the list could
only be one they had one big thing to
care about
and if you try to talk to peter like hey
peter um you know yeah the market you
know the marketing stuff's going well
but had this idea around this feature he
would literally just leave the room if
you ever tried to speak to him about the
non
one thing you were assigned he would
just ignore you he's like oh that's not
a remember we decided what's important
so by definition this is not important
so by definition i'm just not going to
talk about non-important things i'm
going to leave right like i don't know
how hard i don't know how real that
anecdote is because i wasn't there but
like let's just say like directionally
it's true
um
i think that that is like a really
important way to like operate a young
company what happened to the guys from
your office
they ended up getting into yc they ended
up uh getting better they kind of grew
but then they lost like
like once the growth wasn't like instant
here's my read of it they pivoted they
pivoted and disbanded they're all doing
different things now one guy one guy's
like you know working on a different
company another guy's working on a
different company and the third guy i've
never heard i don't know where he went
and um probably found some cocaine
somewhere and he had told me something
once which was just like he was like you
know
once he was like
like they were building a marketplace of
supply and demand and like they the
reason they we were all excited about
them was because they got this huge
amount of supply really quickly
they just posted on reddit and like
people really wanted the thing and so
they started posting but the demand side
was slow and he was like
he's like when i he's like with the len
with the supply side it felt like i
stepped on a land mine i just like did
one i took one step and it just blew up
he goes i want the demand to feel like
that too
dude so
on one hand i respected that on the
other hand i was like dude sometimes you
got to like figure out how to get no to
work i don't respect that and the reason
why is you know we're taught like you
know people can change we can evolve and
i've actually
i think last year i actually made the
decision i'm actually going to assume
people don't change the way you are is
the way you are and you're never
changing
and that
that way of thinking how hopeful of you
it's actually been amazing because like
i'll meet someone and i'm just like oh
you are a loser and you're always going
to be a loser you say you're going to do
something you don't do it you don't have
big dreams you don't work hard like
innocent until people
yeah yours is guilty until proven 100
and then i meet someone who's just like
a baller like steph smith i'm like oh
well you're just a winner so just like
maybe sometimes you're going to swing
and miss but you're always going to
swing therefore i'm on board forever
with anything you do because i know
exactly how you are and people never
change and you're just a winner you win
consistently whereas there's a bunch of
other people i there's this great
article it's called losers exist avoid
them and it's the founder of bleacher
report brian greenberg or goldberg and
he writes a blog post about how he
interviews people he's like yeah see i
just think that losers do exist and like
not everyone's a winner and i'm just
gonna try really hard to avoid those
types of people and his way of doing it
is he would say i asked you about the
bottom fourth of your resume so where
you went to school so if i'm
interviewing a candidate and she can't
tell me like passionately about
something that she studied for four
years it's like oh you're just a loser
like you're not into you you don't care
about philosophy even though you studied
that for four years you're you're
uninteresting and thus are a loser but
you interview this other woman and she
could like passionately tell you a story
about something
and it's like well i don't even care
about philosophy but because you
entertained me like you clearly you are
curious you're a winner so anyway uh my
way of thinking as of late is just uh
people never change
my sister has a great phrase unless you
guys
uh people will say that people don't
change
they change
for the worse
so her default is even worse yeah this
person will change over time they're
going to get worse they're going to
decay basically and like harden in these
like bad patterns
until proven otherwise um
i think that's actually a pretty good
way of thinking about things dude can i
tell you about this last thing like this
experiment i'm doing that
i think relates to this which is like
losers exist how to avoid them so here's
my it's a good line right
it's brilliant here's my my inversion of
that winners exist here's how to attract
them
and so um i put out this thing the other
day i tweeted out this i was like 50 000
thing yeah i was like yo we just made 25
grand uh like a wire just came in for
milk road for 25 grand i did not think
that was gonna work
i want to give it all i want to give it
away and i said that you know crypto has
is full of speculators there's too many
speculators not enough builders so if
you want to build something here's the
deal
i will give away
uh one one each which is like three
thousand dollars i was like i'll give
you 3000 no strings attached no equity
to build whatever you want like you're
you scratch your itch
and um i just want to give it to
builders here here's a link to apply
um go and two kind of amazing things
happen of how like winners exist here's
how to attract them first
a bunch of people who are winners were
like hey great idea i'll put in money
too it was just an excuse to touch base
with like a bunch of these so the prize
pool is more than doubled already and
like now we're giving away more money to
more people because people are like oh
this is cool it was like the calm guy it
was fur khan yeah the founder of com
furcon was like we'll match it and then
like there's more people but we were
like hey let's just give away this first
batch and then like if this is cool
we're gonna like we'll do more we can
just grow this into a self-sustaining
like builder grant it's philanthropy but
like i don't instead of charity i'd
rather give to like people building [__]
and like i'm sorry to you know people
who are like no there's people suffering
out there like yes but also like this is
where i want to give money to is
something like this um and by the way
the whole like a wire came in today that
was all [__] like that was just like
for the story like we just i was just
like i want to give away this i'm
willing to give away this much money
and
people need to realize that lying for
the sake of a story is actually okay
have you remembered the book that we
read uh about storytelling
yes which one story were the story story
worthy and he was like he's like just
lie like for example if you're talking
about like yeah so i was in the car at
my teacher and she started flirting with
me like and he was like well there's
actually like three people in the back
seat but like i couldn't say that
because that wrote the story the thing
was like uh
don't lie to ad lie to omit details yeah
details just omit details that don't add
to the point of the story and um
and so yeah but mine was like i kind of
just framed it as like oh a wire just
came in and because everybody's a wire
could have came in oh it kind of came in
and it did come in in pieces like the
money did come to me somehow
you received
and so like so but basically i told like
this came on a whim so i told you we
heard that new guy safwan and i was like
cephalon uh sappho is 22 i think and
he's awesome and i just like having
winners around me like young awesome
energetic
people who want to like make [__] happen
and i was like yo um i want more people
like you around i'm not going to hire
all of them but like how do i just get
more
like you know what
those peter thiel did that thing where
he like took like young people's blood
and like put it in his body i wanted to
do a legend
yeah i want young young blood in my in
my body how do i how am i gonna do that
so i was like all right let me just put
out a grant for builders this will
attract people who a can build things b
like know what one theory one eth is and
like want one ether like and the three
thousand dollars like mean something to
them that this could like unlock like a
month worth of like it's like an excuse
to go build that thing right
so what happened
almost a thousand applications came in
in a week and how long was an
application
it was like a form that was like you
know uh who what's your i was like
what's your story i was just like kind
of open-ended and it was like uh what do
you want to build give me the tweet
pitch of it why do you want to build it
um you know what's your handle what your
address with your email what blah blah
blah and so people wrote in and i'll
share the air table with you it's kind
of amazing all right so there's like a
bunch of junk we shortlisted um
like about 150 people out of the like
close to a thousand as like strong like
this person's kind of like either their
story or their idea is strong and then
we like kind of got to the finalists
which are like these 35 people that are
like okay these 35 people they all seem
like kind of worthy of getting this and
we're ultimately going to pick like i
don't know 15 or something for the [__]
for this this batch of grants
and um
and i think doing this like this whole
thing is going to take me i think maybe
three days total to like of attention to
pull off but what it's going to create
is like
just a bunch of young awesome energy
young being just like not your literal
age but like more like
people who like psychograms somebody who
yeah it's like somebody who has an idea
has energy has optimism um and like
doesn't think of all the reasons they
shouldn't do it instead they like uh
yeah [__] yeah apply i'm gonna do this
and so they're gonna be around me and i
like i i think this is gonna be so roi
positive in the long run that it's like
insane dude
i've done these things before and i
think you did it before when you gave a
business to someone right
yeah and i've never had it work out
like
yeah it just kind of like
went on the back shelf or they just kind
of forgot about it
yeah it could be uh and like you know
that's why the main filter is like are
you gonna actually do anything or are
you just talking about it or like
is your day job or your you know your
student status whatever gonna just trump
this and you never get around to like
actually making [__] happen that's the
number one criteria here
um but dude the stories are like amazing
of like who writes in it's like it just
reminds you of like oh wow the world is
way bigger
than the like the amount of people that
i interact with on a day-to-day basis
are you giving the money all to one
person
no no no there's gonna be like 15 people
who get the grant and it's like a few
grand each
yeah all right well i'm eager to see
what's happening what's gonna happen
when are you gonna decide
uh we'll decide like in the next five
days who gets it and then we're just
like setting up like we're just gonna
run the whole thing you know just like a
telegram group or something like that
and uh
and yeah we'll see what happens but guys
my point is
do things that create that like attract
winners to you um is this which is the
opposite lesson of like losers and how
to avoid them that's great advice i
think actually slightly less great
advice is winners also exist here's how
to get near them get around them get
them around you
and like figure out different ways to
like get them around you this is one
that like you know
not everybody can afford to like do a
grant program or whatever but like yeah
but if i had no if i had no money i
could have hustled and created this
grant program instantaneously i could
have said i could have emailed you know
50 people and been like hey will you put
up a thousand dollars um for this here's
all the benefits you're gonna get and
you know
which is how by the way i hired safwan
he initially emailed me saying hey you
should do a grant program here's five
reasons why
and i was like oh that's actually a
great idea will you do all the work he
said yeah i'll do all the work did you
ever read uh uh
san francisco's subreddit
no
all right so i used to go to the
subreddit for san francisco all the time
and there was this guy it started like
five years ago he just said hey everyone
and he posted a picture of himself
holding a beer he goes i'm at this
bar i forget it was in hey ashbury i'm
at this bar
come down and your first drink's on me
and he just posted that and like people
made fun of him and then he did it again
the next week and he did this for
literally like 60 weeks in a row and
then he like became famous for the guy
he's like oh you wanna have a good time
this guy seems really nice everyone goes
to talk so he's a really cool dude it'll
buy your first drink whatever you can't
if you do that with like building cool
[__] it actually works out quite well
where it's like hey i'm building this
thing tag along for the ride uh
it tends to work well the guy does it
all the time it's great it's uh he like
became famous for like oh come have
first drinks on me i'm down here i
wonder how much he spent dude we used to
do these mixers these roommate mixtures
uh in san francisco and we would like
only spend five hundred dollars but we
were like the man like we were like the
most popular people for a long time we
did it every week for like two years
well hey what were you doing
500 bucks went to doing what i bought
everyone beer
at a bar or at a bar
you'd host them at a bar and i would
just like hey can i get two dollar beers
and i just come every week and i'll
spend at least 500 and i'm like all
right cool
and so i was like all right here's my
card stop it at 500.
it was pretty sick can we turn the ship
around we need to circle back
business term
let me tell you about a cool company
that i just discovered and the guy told
me to tell you hey so dude i don't know
if you know i don't know if that was
like he's a fan or if or if he actually
knows you have you it's called uh so i i
am i'm linking to it in here in the doc
i'm highlighting it right now it's
called um
getcyberleads.com have you ever seen
this no who so who's the guy uh
well i don't i don't know i don't even
know his name i just dm'd him on uh alex
alex westco
okay uh yeah i don't think i know this
person he said tell sean i said hey
alex west is his name i didn't know if
he was saying it as like a way that he
knows you must just be a fan all right
let's get cyber leads the reason it's
cool is it's just him and
basically what it is is you pay let's
see how much is it is it so you pay
between 100 and a thousand dollars a
month for a different a bunch of
different versions but basically you
every month just one time every month he
sends you a thousand plus hand-picked
companies that just raised a lot of
money and are highly likely to go and
look and look to outsource
whether it's technology or
design they're looking to outsource
stuff and if you're an agency owner you
sign up to this and every month you just
get a bunch of new leads and the lead
list it includes the ceo's name the ceo
ceo's contact information what this
person is likely to outsource where
they're located how big they are and how
much or how much money they just raised
and the reason why this is cool is
because
it's so freaking simple
very clear value it's just one person
it's making three hundred thousand
dollars a year so or sorry yeah three
hundred thousand dollars a year so it's
making um in march he said he did twenty
he did twenty thousand dollars a month
with a net profit of seventeen thousand
dollars it's now gone up to like 30 000
a month but i just thought this was
unique and i love these types of
businesses because the value proposition
is so clear if you just one of these
things closes a deal it's worth it and i
actually think that you could do this
for a bunch of different verticals
you've never seen this before
no i've never ever seen this how does he
do the like what they're likely to
outsource is he just guessing basically
so i asked him something i go are you
doing this hand-picked he goes yeah
every report takes me out uh a hundred
dollars
to do the whole leads list and he sends
one email per month and if you go to the
website and you click live demo
uh you can basically see what he sends
you it's it's just like an air table
an air table table uh and you can kind
of see all the information
wow
that's kind of cool all right this is
pretty cool right
yeah good for him
um and i it's just him and he's like i
was like can this scale he goes i think
i can get a million dollars a year
pretty soon and i'm not sure what i can
do after that but i think just me this
could get a million dollars and honestly
i totally agree i think this is a
beautiful business i think this is
really really cool
so he said okay let's just look at his
march numbers all right so he said
march revenue 20 000 cost 3000 a month
net profit 17k
profit margin 85
last march for example he was basically
five times less so revenue was four
thousand and now it's twenty thousand
and so this is pretty good this is what
basically basically one guy and a va can
run this
um
yeah one guy and one guy and a va can
run this thing and it's providing like
you said it's providing clear value in
the sense that like
if i pay for this i'm likely to get more
customers and make more money so it's
like it pays for itself
and like it pays for itself is actually
a pretty valuable thing which is like
there's a bunch of things in my
businesses that i'm like uh yeah i want
to do that but you know i kind of have
these other priorities and i was like
well
i really do just need to look at all
these things as like can i hire somebody
and it be immediately value like
you know a creative in the next six to
12 months because
that job that i'm hiring them for is not
to just make my life easier it's to
literally generate revenue and profits
and so like there is no way that if i
hire this person if they are competent
this has to be an roi positive thing to
do and you know the only thing i need to
consider is like
do i have the do i ha have the
bandwidth to hire this person and so um
and so to me you know like that's and
then there's products like that too this
is a product like that where it's like
yeah i paid 99 or whatever 199 a month
whatever this thing costs
and like if i can't make more than 199
off this like that's just my own
incompetence at that point it's sick man
it's really sick and so it says it says
there's a thousand leads if you go to
pricing for the prices range from two
hundred dollars to two thousand dollars
and it says let's see it says you get
uh a thousand leads maybe that includes
like all the past months uh it's pretty
this is pretty cool by the way check out
this tweet i put in the chat uh this is
a good example of like
content that's not like um
it's like this is the easy easy mode of
creating content that people resonate
with so this is just a beautiful tweet
all right so this guy tweeted out
december 21st he goes one year again one
year ago today i was fired for my job
making two thousand dollars a month
today i'm making six thousand a month
with my own business and they post more
importantly he posts a screenshot of his
like calendars planner and it says fired
extension point last day at work that's
like on the 21st
on the 22nd day one is self-employed man
expectation point and it's just like you
kind of root for the person
and you know what's in this content it's
nothing but it's like by showing the raw
like planner uh and like what i wrote to
myself that day like these are like
these these have like an emotional
impact on people and i think that's one
thing that most people get wrong in
content is that content is about emotion
not information
and something like that it generates
like a feeling of like rooting for the
person
that is like
most people i know are really smart and
so they try to like outsmart everybody
on content and so you don't need to
outsmart everybody you need to trigger
an emotional response whether it's
outrage it's like compassion it's like
um you know awe-inspiring whatever it is
and uh this is a great simple example of
how you can make somebody root for you
is you know a little tweet like this
this guy's a good find i think he kind
of so there's this guy that for contacts
for the listener there's a guy named
peter lovells who i've been begging to
get on the pod and he keeps like saying
yes and then ghost and yeah so but
anyway this guy peter lovells he's
not exactly a one-man operation i think
now he's got contractors but he's got
like four or five different businesses
they're basically all the same thing
like job boards collectively doing like
four million or
or so in revenue and he posts like cute
cool insightful content on twitter and
blogs this guy alex west is kind of like
in the same ballpark as that as that guy
peter levels
right like he's it's like cool well
designed it looks like he's like a like
a nomad as well uh
but uh
somebody needs to make the list i feel
like steph smith needs to do this she
needs to make the definitive list of
these like
solopreneur freelancer digital nomad
basically like the peter levels this guy
where it's like yeah this person's on
some journey they're trying to get to
100k a month in like personal revenue
but they have these principles like
they're not trying to raise money
they're not trying to build a big team
they live nomadically they're like just
a good enough engineer and just good
enough designer and just a good enough
copywriter to make it happen and they're
like doing it all in public and like
there's like 20 of these people that i
found on twitter all of them are
entertaining to me and i feel like most
people just don't know who those people
are and like actually like a good
service would be to just aggregate them
and put it in a newsletter be like hey
i'm following all these people doing
this thing check this out this guy
posted an update about this thing and
like you can just make a newsletter
following their work and probably like
you know build an audience of 50 to 100
000 people following you following them
which is sort of you know meta do you
ever read indie hackers
uh i don't personally go there much but
i have for sure in the past indie
hackers is awesome it's started by his
two guys cortland and channing um
they're twins yeah i've become friends
with channing over the years basically
indeed it was like a forum for this
weird genre of entrepreneurs called
indie hackers but they sold it to stripe
and i have a feeling
that each brother will make in the world
of 20 million dollars when stripe goes
public i wouldn't be surprised if it
were a little more but i can't i
actually think it's above 20. they've
never told me i just i'm guessing
because because of when they sold to
them
and if they sold for a million dollars
it would have gone up by like that much
so anyway uh
i on their website they list interviews
and they list all the revenue of the
companies and it's pretty amazing and
you can sort by revenue and you can just
find like a list of companies that
basically you want to like get inspired
by or copy right yeah that's cool uh and
by the way just look at their traffic
like their traffic shows about a million
million to a million and a half monthly
visitors so you know good good job by
them of like this is like real scale and
in fact this is probably like like for
milk road i should go tell our story on
indie hackers and product hunt i could
probably add
10 000 new subscribers
with
one day of one day of like just crafting
a story that goes on just posting on
both of these i completely agree i've
done it both times
we did it for trends we made a lot of
money
i like it hopspot allows all our teams
to work together seamlessly so no one's
falling overboard unless we want them to
um okay what else you got
i don't know you tell me what do you got
i see what another says wait i have a
question all right yeah let's let me ask
you i think i see this question you're
about to ask me all right
you ever seen those movies where they
are it's about like drug lords and [__]
and do you find and you see just like a
normal guy in a boat off the coast of
florida and he finds like a brick of
cocaine
yeah like if you're like seeing that
like premise my question to you is if
you because i'm reading this book uh
have you seen the movie no country for
old men
no
um so it's like a movie
i've heard of it but you know what it is
that name to me sounds so boring that i
will never click on that no it's not a
boring one at all it's like a thriller
but i'm reading the book and basically
the premise is this guy like comes
across a drug deal gone bad everyone's
dead at the scene and there's two and a
half million dollars as well as a truck
full of cocaine he takes the two million
dollars
the drug
guys look for him and that's the that's
the book and my question is if i came
across that cocaine
what would i do
and what would you do if you came across
like i have no idea how cocaine is
measured but like
that movie scene where you come across
like a hat yeah or many bricks i guess
what do you what do you do with it
take a picture put it on instagram be
like oh my god get the social clout and
get the hell out of there i am not
picking up the cocaine i'm not becoming
a drug dealer i'm not gonna figure out
how to flip this you could also replace
that with like oh i find uh
you know a large supply of copper wires
which have a like decent market value
i don't know i've actually been down
this path before once i think i talked
about this on the pod where
we met a guy who had this giant
uh
comic book card collection yes and like
we had this opportunity to buy it for
like probably like 10 cents on the
dollar of what it was like what the
individual like some of all the parts
would have been
but we had to like figure out like what
the hell to do it's like here's a
warehouse you now have the cost of this
warehouse and you have all this stuff
and none of it's graded and none of it's
like categorized none of it's
inventoried it's like you know you gotta
go do that like you know american picker
style like junkyard flip type thing for
this stuff
and when i kind of like i got excited at
first because it was like it would have
been a like multi-million dollar flip if
we had done it how did that end
it ended with me realizing this is not
worth the time and energy to go do this
like this is so much energy well so the
story was basically you came across a
guy who owned a warehouse and he used it
really old guy really old guy who was
like finally ready to like sell his
thing he'd been collecting for 30 years
like tens of millions of like baseball
cards or something yeah like he had
millions of cards most of which are
useless but for sure some of it is
valuable and like the question is like
and you had to buy the whole lot you had
to buy the whole like thing and then
what did you do with it deal with it
i think he did no nobody bought it
because again nobody wants this headache
and like even the discount like i was
like okay let's say this is discounted
you know based on our estimates this
thing's discounted like 90
even at a 90 discount the like mental
overhead the literal overhead and like
some people out there like dude i would
have done it and like you should go do
it if you have no better options get you
should go do this but for me i was like
wow this is a lot of work so i would not
i wouldn't do it in the legal case let
alone the illegal case of figuring out
how to flip these bricks of cocaine is
kind of my answer what's your answer to
that it depends what stage of life i'm
in um like all right so let's take it by
decade you're 20 i'm 20. and like one of
these bricks if could they be worth like
two million dollars let's say the whole
thing is worth uh you know six million
dollars if you if you you know sold it
all at like street value so let's start
at the end of you having all this cash
let's say you have
as you know we do we do move straight to
the end i'm moving straight to the end
assuming that i had six million dollars
in cash i wouldn't even know what to do
with that if you buy a if you buy a
if you buy property with six million
dollars in cash how can you even do that
are you even allowed to do that i mean
where would you keep that money
yeah i don't know what you would do
you'd have to like figure out how to
like launder it basically to like
legitimately own it or you'd have to
figure out a way to like
do some you know off uh off
over-the-counter transaction of like
gold bars or something else or do you
just live a cat like a cash life forever
yeah you go under the mattress
you just pay for everything
with tens of twenties uh this is
breaking bad right this is the plot of
breaking bad basically so what would i
do if all right if i was 20 and i found
it i i i don't even think i'm taking it
i don't even know what i would do i i
would not be
maybe when i was 20 maybe i wouldn't be
opposed to trying something but i
literally would have no idea where to
start where would you even start i don't
know people who do i don't even know i
don't know people who do cocaine i don't
hang out with anybody but you're in the
moment you have to make a split decision
in the heat of the moment i would have
bet
we'll figure it no i'd have to call the
cops i think i would call the police i
wouldn't know what to do i wouldn't even
know how to execute this
yeah that okay so that's one uh if
you're not gonna do in your 20s you're
not going to do it in your 30s yes i
don't i don't think it matters what
stage of life you're in uh there is a
couple other you know methods here right
so like
let's say you're in this what was the
the old white country for old men or
something like that like you know
basically the guy finds the briefcase
if i find that briefcase i'm taking 15
of the cash out i'm leaving the rest
there because who's really going to
chase me down for the 15 percent so i
think i get like you know 80 you know i
get like really
none of the work is the easiest so i did
the math so the book was set in 1979 and
it was two and a half million dollars
which is the equivalent of like eight
million dollars today so finally eight
million dollars today and this is set in
el paso texas and the guy lives on a
trailer like a mobile home so seven
million dollars might as well be 700
million dollars it's just a world
world-changing thing if i'm that guy
like that's easy you just find it you
get the car and you just never go back
home and you just you're just gone
yeah but i'm i'm what am i gonna do
sleep you know with one eye open every
night wondering what's gonna happen
if i see that 2 million i'm taking 247
000 out no
they're they're never going to they're
going to not even understand why 247
we're 247 000 short and i'm living a
happy calm lifestyle just as my life was
but with an extra 247 000 that's my
that's my move that's so funny i i don't
think i could take 15 i would yeah i
would definitely take the whole thing i
was thinking about this the other day
this came up uh i watched survivor yeah
i'm like still watching you know season
48 of whatever survivor that's that's
going on and and shout out to the
survivor casting directors i'm i'm
getting in shape so that i can go on
survivor soon um but they have this new
twist where they have this thing you
find normally it's like survivor you go
out in the wild and they have this this
little prize called the immunity idol if
you find this thing you're safe from the
vote you won't get voted out this week
so people always want that thing and
they when they find it it's this joyous
moment they unroll unscroll the scroll
and they're like yes i found the thing
but they added a twist this time which
it says on the top of the scroll it says
beware
like this is called a beware advantage
like you know there could be something
good this this comes with power but also
you know some drawbacks
and they say you could just put this
down right now
and you can go on with the game as it is
or if you open this you have to you know
you get the power but you get the
disadvantage as well you get the
advantage and disadvantage
100 of the time they open up the scroll
and i'm just thinking there i'm like you
know the game theory here is that this
is going to put me in a sticky spot
they're not giving me something that's
gonna give me like it's mostly great
with a tiny downside it's gonna be like
potentially great later with a downside
today right like if i'm the game that's
how i'm organizing this game but
everybody picks it up and everybody
opens it and i thought what are the
things in life that are like this which
is like you pick it up you know you
shouldn't do this
you know this has like drawbacks but you
can't resist you just do it anyways
because you know yellow and like i
started thinking about like what that is
in real life right like there's that
with food like most junk food is that
way you know pleasure now pain later um
you know but what are the other areas of
life you know what is the career version
of this this is like that you got that
really great job
um but like now like you know you were
thinking about maybe you wanted to start
your own business or do your own thing
but then you get this like you know job
at mckinsey and you're tempted to take
it because it has the prestige and it
has the money but it also comes with a
sticky trap of like
this is for sure going to set you on a
path for multiple years in a direction
that you don't think you want to be your
end goal but you do it anyways and so
i'm now looking out for these what i'm
calling the beware the beware advantages
of life the big takeaway here though is
with you wanting to go on survivor so
let me tell you about something so
there's this podcast called dead eyes do
you know what dead eyes is no never
heard of all right so years ago tom
hanks was the producer of band of
brothers you know it was like the tv
show on hbo about
world war ii
and there was this one comedian who was
like an extra of one of the guys who was
shooting or something and tom hanks like
looked at him and then whispered in the
producer or whispered in his assistant's
ear and said like hey hey man you gotta
go uh tom hanks apparently said that he
had quote dead eyes and he wanted him
off the set like he just didn't like him
as an extra something that probably
happens all the time he just thought and
so flicks yeah it wasn't working out and
so this this guy
created a podcast called dead eyes and
the whole podcast was questioning why he
got kicked off like a beta brother that
same guy okay yes
the whole podcast the whole premise is
like he's interviewing people on band of
brothers like asking like why do you
think i got kicked off like what like
let's talk through this dude how did you
find this sounds like the most obscure
of the obscure well
eventually tom hanks goes on it oh my
god that's amazing and he lands tom
hanks and he comes on out again as a
guest and he explains like what what was
happening from his perspective and what
we need to do with you
wait hold on what was the explanation
what did he say or he was just like i
don't remember
he yeah he was like i i don't like i'm
sorry it wasn't let me see
he's like hey this has haunted you for
24 years yeah he was like this i guess
it just it just wasn't even like a he
didn't really think about it i believe
um
apparently he said that like it maybe
even it was like a mistake like maybe he
said the wrong thing uh to the wrong
person but like it was just it just
dismissed him
um
like it wasn't even like an issue in his
life and this guy has this whole podcast
called dead eyes
you've not heard of this it's hilarious
no that's that's hilarious what were you
gonna tie that in you said i should do
something well so with you wanting to be
on on survivor we need to like have you
go through the whole process and you're
likely going to get turned down at the
audition but we got to like do like a
whole series of episodes of you going
through this process of getting on
survivor and documenting it and getting
off that's a great idea that's a great
idea and we like
what you need to do is comment get the
person who does casting for survivor and
act like you want them to come on as a
guest and we could do it just to like
humor them but like on air be like so
like
can shawn audition
yeah i have auditioned before already so
i've been rejected once uh so i already
got that under my belt now oh no we
gotta have them on and we'll do it like
funny like you know i think i said this
earlier like
wouldn't it be funny if we just started
kissing right now like wouldn't that be
hilarious
like that's gotta be it's good if i was
on yeah like it's just hilarious
can you imagine if i came on the
survivor and if it would happen yeah is
that allowed yeah would it be funny
dude
what is the exact line though wouldn't
it be funny
what would happen we just kissed right
now maybe
there's that
there's that one and then there's the
other one that gets me so bad is like
you've heard have you heard this joke
where it's like
and then everybody started clapping
no
okay so basically this is it's like a
recurring joke that comes in when like
if you tell a story yeah like it's like
when somebody tells a story and by the
end of the story you're like you're sort
of like wait what was the point of the
story then you realized the point of the
story was them saying them just saying
how cool they were in a way that was
like not even like the stories kind of
exaggerated or not really believe it's
like yeah we're at the restaurant and
then this guy was choking and then like
but like nobody heard him
but i just saw it i was on my way to the
bathroom and i just kind of like you
know whatever just did the heimlich but
i'd only ever watched a video and like
you're like what is the story where is
this going why are you telling me this
and then
and then you basically like it's an
awkward silence at the end of the story
and they're like and then they basically
they realize the story didn't do it and
so they have to one-up it and just say
and then everybody started clapping
and so it's it's this genre of stories
these there and then everybody started
clapping stories my verses also crack me
up when i see someone get stuck in a
story like that
i'm like oh
yes it's happening they got themselves
trapped in a and then everybody started
clapping story and they're about to
start exaggerating because the story
itself didn't hit and now they're stuck
my version of that is and then i found
five dollars yeah exactly
dude okay so i have a crazy story like
this somebody tweeted this at us they
loved your orlando bloom story by the
way
oh that's i mean that's the one where i
did i didn't want to get stuck in that
that spot but that story is all true so
so somebody tweeted at this this at us
and they go this seems like it's up your
alley and that's when you know you're
winning when somebody sends you
something really weird and they say i
think this is up your alley and it's 100
of my alley this is my home address is
in this alley and so
he sent me this post and it's like a
forum post and he goes
what i'm doing is insane so here's what
it says it goes
i have a bot running 24 7 that is buying
and selling for zero target profit just
to just to waste the irs's manpower and
money i print and send the irs all the
documentation about every one of these
trades in paper form so that they can't
automate it or like you know just like
get through my my report in an easy way
he goes i will sometimes mix blank pages
double print ghost print use mark use
black and white i will number the pages
and put them in out of order i will have
people randomly scribbling drawings of
dicks into the into the pages um i will
send it as a whole palette of paper
trades i even to send this palette i
have to hire a guy with a forklift just
to send it um and i want it to be in a
pallet so that is maximum actually like
troublesome for them and then it says
like you know um
is this real
yeah i don't know if it's really nice
it's like some forum posting goes this
cost me thousands of dollars every year
and i make sure to send them an invoice
so that they know that i'm paying real
money on top of the pallet that i've
sent them um so whoever's in charge of
this knows that i'm wasting the
equivalence of two months of their wage
on this asinine behavior on top of
wasting their time and i was just like
this needs to go to petty court it's
like who are you why are you so troubled
and like
okay you know if you just wasted a
little bit of your own time that's
offensive to me but if you waste all of
your time and money at this point it
turns into respect from my point of view
and like i don't know what your mission
is i don't even really understand it but
i i respect the mission-drivenness of
this like of this initiative
there's no game it's just mutually
assured destruction on both parties it's
like have you seen our uh south park
where cartman is dressed up like steve
jobs at the at the keynote and he's
walking around and he goes
um instead of saying thank you he just
says [__] you [__] you [__] you and the
whole presentation is ways that they're
wasting money and uh he's sitting around
walking around the stage and he goes but
we didn't just stop there you see we
moved the couch from the left part of
the room to the right part of the room
and the whole presentation is just how
they just reorganized the furniture in
his office that quarter that was all
they did with all their money and this
is a good example of that
[Music]
you